Is this a real picture or a fake one?
It's fake hello world.
It's Saroj and there's a new paper from
nvidia research that details an AI model
that can generate images that are more
realistic than any previous model.
It's called a generative adversarial
network or again for short,
but not just any.
Again,
it's again that can progressively grow
over time during the training phase,
which is such a cool idea.
Gans were invented by a researcher at the
University of Montreal three years ago
and its potential is huge because it
can learn to mimic any distribution of
data.
That means it can be taught to create
worlds that are eerily similar to our own
in any domain. Images,
music, speech writing.
They're like robotic artists and
their outputs are pretty impressive.
Speech synthesis systems are using them
image to image translation techniques,
use them and image in painting
is another popular use case.
Gans are a type of generative algorithm.
The other class of models being
discriminative algorithms,
discriminative algorithms try to classify
input data given some set of features
predict a label or category
to which that data belongs to.
If we have all the words in an email.
For example,
a discriminative algorithm could predict
whether the message is spam or not.
Spam,
spam being one of the labels,
the bag of words we gather from the email
or the features that constitutes the
input data.
When we express this mathematically,
the label is called y and
the features are called x.
The formulation probability of y given
x translates to the probability that an
email is spam given the words it contains.
So discriminative algorithms
map features to labels.
They're only concerned with correlations.
One way to think about
generative algorithms though
is that they do the complete
opposite. Instead of predicting
a label, given some features,
they try to predict features
given a certain label,
like assuming this email is spam,
how likely are these features?
Discriminative models care about
the relation between y and X.
Generative models care
about how you get x.
This allows us to capture the
probability of x given why it learns the
distribution of individual classes,
not the boundary.
Dan's consist of two neural networks,
a generative network that generates new
data instances and the discriminator
that evaluates them for authenticity.
The discriminator,
we'll decide whether
each instance of data,
it reviews belongs to the
actual training Dataset or not.
Let's say we're trying to
generate new types of Pokemon.
I just had play that for a second.
Okay.
Using an image Dataset
of existing Pokemon,
the goal of the discriminator when
shown a Pokemon is to recognize it as
authentic.
Meanwhile,
the generator is creating new images
that it passes to the discriminator.
It's trying to fool the discriminator,
trying to pass it off as authentic,
even though it's fake.
The goal of the generator is to generate
passable Pokemon to lie without being
caught.
The goal of the discriminator is to
identify images from the generator as fake
or real.
The steps again takes are as follows.
The generator takes in randomly
generated numbers and returns an image.
This generated image is fed into the
discriminator alongside a stream of
Pokemon.
From the actual Dataset,
the discriminator takes in both real and
fake Pokemon and returns probabilities.
A number between zero and one with one
representing a prediction of authentic
and zero representing fake.
So there's this double
feedback loop going on.
The discriminator is in a feedback loop
with the ground truth of the images,
which we know the generator is in a
feedback loop with the discriminator.
Think of it like a counterfeiter and a
cop in a game of cat and mouse where the
counterfeiter tries to print fake money
and the cop is trying to detect it.
Both are learning at the same time.
The discriminator is a
standard convolutional network
that can classify images
fed to it.
It's essentially a binomial classifier
labeling images as real or fake.
The generator is an inverse convolutional
network or deep convolutional network.
A CNN takes an image and down samples
it to produce a probability and a DNN
takes a vector of random noise
and up samples it into an image.
Both networks tried to optimize a
different and opposing loss function,
so gans are awesome,
but they're really hard to train.
Usually the loss function for gans looks
something like this instead of what it
should look like,
which is something like this.
And that's what makes them
an active area of research.
The idea that Nvidia had was
to grow again progressively.
It wasn't a new idea.
There was a paper that presented
a cascaded reinforcement
approach that brought
small generated images up to
mega pixel size step by step.
Another paper built an intermediate low
dimensional representation than improved
it on another again,
but these methods made their
progressive improvements separately.
The next level of progressive improvement
just took a result of the previous
layers and has paper use a system
where they trained a few layers,
then added a few more and so on.
It turns out that this type of
execution was the most straightforward,
fastest to train and
provided the best results.
The authors begin with a small network
able to produce only four by four images.
Then they train it until it works well.
Then add another set of layers to both
the generator and the discriminator.
Moving from four by four to eight by
eight train the new layers and so on.
Doing this,
they were able to grow again,
able to generate really convincing 10 24
by 10 24 images of much better quality
than before.
One tweak I found particularly interesting
was that they implement it a way to
help their Gan increase its variation.
Dan's have this tendency to capture only
a subset of the variation found in the
training data.
One solution was to compute features,
statistics not only from individual
images but across a mini batch.
This encouraged many batches of generated
and training images to show similar
statistics.
It's implemented by adding a mini
batch layer towards the end of the
discriminator where the layer learns
a large tensor that projects the input
activation to an array of statistics.
A separate set of stats is produced
for each example in a mini batch and
concentrated to the layers output so
the discriminator can use those stats
internally.
They sampled this approach by first
computing the standard deviation for each
feature in each spacial
location over the mini batch.
Then the average,
all of those estimates over all features
and spatial locations to get a single
value.
The value was replicated and contained
to all spatial locations and over the
minibatch which yielded
one additional feature map.
They inserted it towards the end of
the network and it turns out doing that
helped again learn more of the
variation inherent in the training data.
They trained their network on a single
and video Tesla Gpu for 20 days and after
that there was no real difference in
the qualitative difference between the
results of training iterations.
It's pretty incredible the images
they were able to generate not 100%
photorealistic,
but really close the fakes dense pose
and now progressively growing gans.
We are heading towards some
unpredictable and exciting times.
Three things to remember from this video.
A generative adversarial network consists
of two neural networks of generator
and a discriminator.
The generator creates fake images.
The discriminator tries to discern if
it's real or if it's fake. Over time,
both get better through a training
phase and and video found that by
progressively adding
layers to both networks,
it improved the quality of the
outputs and sped up the training time.
This week's coding challenge
is to generate some
photorealistic images using a
progressively growing gan details and
code are in the video description.
Submit your get hub link
in the comments section.
I'll review them and announce
the top two entries in a week.
Was this video itself generated?
Maybe it's a tried to keep up with the
latest in AI and block chain technology.
For now, I've got to generate a
website, so thanks for watching.